hello everyone and welcome to another
crazy and complicated game from round
four of this year's fed Grand Swiss it
is Serbian Grand Master Alexander PR
versus Indian Grand Master Arjun erigi
you've seen two rounds ago how Alexander
pret masterfully uh well completely
destroyed Yang shishto Duda it was it
was a really an attacking Masterpiece if
you haven't seen it I've made a video on
it do check it out uh and here he also
launches uh a very strong attack against
Arjun so let's see how this game went
for him
Alexander has the white pieces and he
opens with D4 we have Knight to F6 C4 uh
we have E6 Knight to F3 and pawn to D5
so the standard Queen's gamb declined
Knight to C3 and pawn to C5 going for
the semit tar defense we have C captures
on D5 Knight captures and now Pawn to E4
so all been played before nothing new
here Knight captures B captures and now
C captures on D4 we have C captures on
D4 and Bishop to B E4 check we have
Bishop to D2 and captures and captures
we have castles and now there
are probably around 1,00 games in the
database from from uh top tier
tournaments where this position has been
reached it's it really is the main line
and Bishop to C4 is the main move
sometimes they go Bishop to E2 some Rook
C1 maybe bishop to B5 but Bishop to C4
is the top move here uh Magnus himself
has played it many times he defeated Kik
twice with Bishop to C4 he played
against ding once uh they got a draw uh
he also plays this position with black
so it's a very well-known position but
here Alexander plays Pawn to H3 and this
is a move that has never been played
before so what does it do I have no idea
I have some ideas because I've already
seen the game uh but I think it's just
to to mess with arjun's head so let's
see how Arjun deals with this he plays
Pawn to B6 he says all right this is not
really doing all that much let's just
develop our light Square Bishop to this
long diagonal
uh Rook to D1 and Bishop to D7 with
Bishop to D3 okay defending D4 Pawn also
putting the bishop on this beautiful
diagonal Knight to C6 putting pressure
on the D4 Pawn so Queen E3 defending the
pawn and now Rook to C8 so as you can
see Arjun also getting some very rapid
development in due to White throwing in
this H3 move castles even and now Rook
to E8 we have Bishop back to B1 now you
know that the bishop will be controlling
this diagonal for a very long long time
and you have to figure out when white
will play E5 or D5 to open up um this
light Square Bishop fully so Knight to
A5 going after the C4 square and believe
it or not this is where Alexander plays
it he plays Pawn to D5 now of course he
will not trade on D5 it's a pawn
sacrifice he wants to give up this Pawn
in order to advance this Pawn to E5 and
that will open up his light Square
Bishop so okay e captures on D5 Pawn to
E5 like the Old Masters did while while
attacking uh and now you have to already
be very very careful now the Knight
might come to G5 the queen might find
her uh way somehow into the attack so
how do you defend well Knight to C4
let's see what Alexander plans for his
queen queen to F4 and now Queen to C7
attacking the E5 Pawn three times uh but
now just Rook F to E1 okay defending the
pawn not a problem Rook to E7 adding
more support to the seventh rank uh and
now there are moves you could consider
here like maybe Rook E2 followed by Rook
to E1 you simply double up on the E file
maybe you put the Rook to C1 because
there's a queen on C7 uh maybe you play
some other useful moves but no uh
Alexander goes Bishop captures on H7 uh
so he goes he goes
for kingside attack like he did against
Yang Shish of Duda King captures on H7
and now Queen to H4 okay the queen
defends The Rook but you know that
Knight to G5 is coming so can you go to
G8 of course it's your only move unless
you want to get destroyed so Knight to
G5 and now uh the threat of course is
Queen to H7 check followed by King to f8
and then Queen to h8 will be Checkmate
so you can't play something like Knight
captures on E5 because then your king is
stuck however you can play Rook captures
on E5 and this is what Arjun plays this
will now free up the E7 Square for the
king so Queen to H7 with check King to
f8 and now Queen to h8 with check King
to E7 and now Queen captures on G7 okay
you've opened up the black kings
position you've grabbed some pawns for
the piece uh obviously the attack is
doing well but let's see how Arjun
defends Rook captures on E1 Rook
captures and now King to D6 uh is there
a way to continue the attack Queen to F6
with check King to C5 even we have Rook
to E7 going after the black queen and
now Queen to D6 offering a queen trade
uh and here Alexander just plays Queen
captures on F6 seven and now if you
count the the the material Arjun is uh
down a pawn but he is up a piece he has
a light Square Bishop for a pawn now
that's obviously winning if he can get
his King to safety now what would you
play here in this position it's a very
tricky position where a couple of moves
are nice but there's only one real uh
winning attempt for black so uh just
just give it give it a try you know just
test your spidey sense how would you
deal with this position while I give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting uh
King to B4 as that is what Arjun played
but that is not the winning move it
could be as the game still continues the
winning move is Bishop to C6 this um
allows the black king to to be
completely safe while black organizes an
attack against the white king point is
that now okay you could uh try some
moves maybe you go after the queen then
the queen moves or you go after the king
best is Knight to E6 check King to B4
and now let's say Knight to D4 and now
again you keep the bishop safe Bishop to
A4 and now once white plays Rook
captures on A7 or something is there's
really no other way to attack now you
play Knight to A5 and now this is the
setup you have to have in order to have
your position defended and now it's
black to start counterattacking now The
Rook will G to C4 kick away the Knight
and then you will start advaning ing the
past D on to Victory while the queen
covers the H2 square and the white will
not really have resources to pursue this
any further so that is the way to
Victory here however King to B4 was
played and now uh how do you react to
this do you just capture the bishop it's
a very very enticing idea for sure uh
let's see what happens if Rook captures
on B7 then arjun's idea was Knight to A5
just going after the rook and also
preparing Rook to C1 check as the queen
covers the H2 Square so you're going to
have to defend against Checkmate and
then Knight captures on B7 Queen
captures and now just Rook C7 uh you
defend and you will play uh with this
Rook against Knight um uh maybe not 100%
winning but uh you will definitely have
great winning chance it is objectively
winning it's very hard to say if he
would um be able to win it probably he
would so that's uh the the uh the idea
behind Rook captures on B7 but he
doesn't go for that he actually goes for
Rook to D7 he doesn't want to capture
the bishop as this will give him uh more
of a fighting chance so Rook to D7 and
now what is arjun's idea here uh Queen
to E5 sort of still keeps black in the
game but I think as they were both very
low on time Arjun decided that he wants
to call it a day he played Knight to D2
he gave up his Queen and he was in this
position un move 31 that uh Alexander PR
and arjuni agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here uh yes it
looks like the queen is hanging but of
course if the queen is captured then you
know what follows if Rook captures on U
D6 Rook to C1 with check or maybe maybe
they agreed to a draw in this position
maybe it was that position maybe it was
this one probably was this one the
previous one looks a bit pretty mature
so yeah let's call this one I can even
check yeah I don't want to trick you
guys let's just check yeah after Rook to
C1 they've agreed to a draw uh because
of the thing that I've already said King
to H2 will would be played and now
Knight to f one check you control G3 and
H2 the King has to go back King G1 you
go again Knight G3 a discovery you go
back then again Knight to F1 check if
you go to H1 you can even go Knight to
D2 just for fun King H2 go back Knight
to F1 check and it will be a draw by
three-fold repetition so a very very
Fierce play by Alexander petk
who took down Duda with the white pieces
with a with a similar attack now he
tried it against Arjun Arjun defended
well but not well enough to actually
uh take a full point here uh but yeah
Alexander pra just playing incredible
chess here and we'll see if he if he
will attempt such a thing again uh with
the white pieces so he's two for two for
now uh but yeah they they split a point
here and uh you know uh Fair result
definitely uh so that's the game I hope
you guys enjoyed it very nice Kings side
attack by by Alexander but also very
nice defense by Arjun just marching his
King all the way to be before uh the the
you know strongest Square on the board I
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to din no vodopia and I would like to
thank John gear Law Office Mario Milano
the Brutus on Spotify and Steven mccan
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the FED Grand
Swiss uh until it finishes so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your
day